même dans une chambre et qu'un petit
ordi à micro une baffe et on peut on
peut faire on va voir on peut faire de
grandes choses
[Applaudissements]
à
mon père y faisait des tours pour
m'endormir il m'endormais que la musique
dans la voiture et je me demande donc la
musique c'est depuis petit joris tôt au
collège j'ai décidé de rentrer milliers
de d'aller prendre un micro à 20 euros
de webcams l'a pas fait sur la papeterie
là j'ai pris ça près match et tu
télécharges un triplé audacity hunx
kraft entre contient sa table et j'ai en
fait je prenais les instrus des des
genres déjà coûté 1 1 sont des
psychiatres ou la fff ou un truc comme
ça je prends je prenais le la fin s'il
restait de l'instru je le prenais joe
cole et son fils aîné ce truc et après
je chantais dessus je mange moins au
début c'est un peu nul mais j'ai
continué
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
ouais
l'objectif déjà ces deux de demain musée
de me régaler devant le devant le micro
mme devant leurs hôtes j'essaie de créer
des choses c'est ça mon seul but c'est
de faire plaisir aux gens de leur
montrer qu'avec le travail on peut avec
peu on peut faire de grandes choses
c'est l'avenir parce qu'à la base on non
plus comme ça les dépôts témoin plus
comme ça en rigolant gens pensent que je
faisais tu faisais des jeux fédé sont
presque tous les tous les deux jours et
tout et tout le temps là j'écris ou même
koch rien en faire fut là j'écris je
trouve des étudiants ce truc sur youtube
[Musique]
mais
là on a mis des douleurs ouais je donne
à tous les repas c'est un match
ouais j'ai acheté le tiche faire sans
ces assises ont mis des heures
[Musique]
j'aime tous condamnés à tous vos besoins
[Applaudissements]
non